we get to put it away yes and we get on
to other things
brad pitt and jennifer aniston are
apparently keeping things platonic
so everyone calm down yeah or
keep or don't and stay excited and
possibly something will happen
leading up to jennifer's big reunion
thursday night e.t has new details about
one of her other
friendly relationships the one she has
with ex-husband
brad oh god there's a lot of highlights
a source tells e.t
there's nothing romantic there but they
are definitely aware that their fans are
constantly rooting for them to get back
together and laugh about it together
the source adds that jen and brad
sometimes like to egg on the media
frenzy surrounding them
in a playful way the source also said
the exes
respect each other and think each other
are both wildly
talented and hilarious and these new
details come after last year's
epic reunion and i'm really happy this
one lined up for
us backstage at the screen actors guild
awards these photos of brad and jen
sent shock waves through the internet
and leading up to that
eagerly awaited moment brad told et he
wasn't nervous about a potential reunion
okay the obsession the world the
internet everyone is waiting they're
hoping for this moment where you and
jennifer run into each other so they can
take their picture
i'll run into jen she's a good friend
yeah so they can
you know you know how this goes the
second the second most
important reunion ever of of her year
exactly i understand you know how that
works
18 pages front and back front and back
is correct and with anticipation running
high
the night of the sag awards aniston gave
e.t her reaction to the ongoing frenzy
what do you make of all the
ridiculousness it's hysterical but what
else are they going to talk about
good call jen people became obsessed
with their backstage reunion but
even after two weeks brad told et he was
still
oblivious to the enormous response on
social media
awards season has been so fun what do
you make of our reaction to the big
reunion backstage last week at the set
i don't know i'm blissfully naive and
i'm going to stay that way
you haven't been on the internet nope
and also we know brad and jen
don't mind collaborating for a good
cause brad
what character you're going to be
reading oddly enough i will be reading
brad they both appeared in last summer's
celebrity cast reading of
fast times at ridgemont high organized
by comedian
dane cook which benefited a non-profit
organization
helping communities amid the pandemic
and gave us this
adorable scene reenactment
hi brad you know how cute i always
thought you were
i think you're so sexy will you come to
me
wait just a minute oh god i'm so sorry i
did not know anybody was in here